nearly every single damn video that
Graham Steffen has posted in the last
five months have well over a hundred
thousand views each held nearly all of
his videos on his second channel where
he kind of just rants for like 15
minutes straight I just love that little
last slogan er millennial money not even
his main focus has well over a hundred
thousand views and when you see that
bigger names in the space like Grant
Cardone value tame it the man in the red
suit that you all know but I'm not gonna
say his name because it's trademarked
and you know don't sue me bro
he'll even Gary be the king of social
media himself who have dedicated staffs
of cameramen video editors entire
production teams what more subscribers
in Graham can barely crack 50,000 views
on each of their videos when you see all
of this you have to wonder what is
Graham Steffen doing differently than
everyone else so in this video we're
gonna look at the key factors of why
Graham Steffen is beating the YouTube's
algorithm and how you can do the same so
sit back relax and enjoy the show
[Music]
there's this myth that to succeed on
YouTube you need to post as much as you
can the more the better so you might as
well just post every single day if you
have the manpower me with a team of 20
putting out between 80 and a hundred
pieces of original content a day let me
be the one to say that that is a big fat
lie one of the biggest differences
between Graham and at least the big
names that I mentioned earlier is that
we're these big guys post seven days a
week
Graham moly post three times yet with
less videos he gets more engagement more
views more loyal offense I just keep
coming back again and again an overall
faster growth within the next few weeks
to a few months
Graham is gonna pass these guys think
about that for a second one man planning
doming editing these videos by himself
living in one side of a duplex to save
money is able to out YouTube guys with
entire teams behind them why one word
scarcity okay there are actually a few
reasons but this is the first one
think about it from your perspective
you're scrolling through YouTube you see
another video from garyvee and you know
that's probably just some recording of a
keynote he gave or a consulting session
he did while filming at the same time
and he's not even addressing you the
viewer directly half of the time the
video sounds like it's probably pretty
interesting but you know if you don't
watch this one there's just gonna be
another one posted tomorrow anyway so
it's okay if you miss this one but then
you come across a video from Kurtz Gaza
aka in a nutshell and you know that I
only post twice a month a fraction of
what Gary B and others like him post on
top of black you know that it takes them
well over 400 to 500 hours to make one
of these videos writing the script
storyboard designing all the staff
recording the narration animation sound
design and composing original music you
know that they actually pour their heart
and soul into each one of these videos
to make them as perfect satisfying and
engaging as they can because they're
just genuinely passionate about making
great videos we all have real jobs and
do cuts cuz out late nights and on the
weekends because it's our passion or in
other words they built up so much trust
with you that the moment you see a new
video from them you instantly click and
watch all the way through to support one
of your favorite creators especially
since you know that you're not gonna see
another video for at least two weeks
this is the same thing that happens to a
brand albeit on a smaller scale every
video you've watched from Graham you can
tell that he made it specifically for
you he didn't just repurpose some
keynote he did to save time no you can
tell that he's making videos for the
sake of making great engaging videos for
his audience not to just always shove a
course on her face or asked you to join
their free masterclass
is this income even though you can't go
to the grocery store and buy your like
haterade
cream or whatever you buy Cardone
capital calm today and click on schedule
a call for more information
and when you've experienced this
multiple times he's built up a good
reputation with you on table you also
know that he doesn't post as frequently
as others so when you see a video from
him in your newsfeed you know that if
you don't watch it there's not gonna be
another one tomorrow what's up guys it's
Graham here and because we value things
that are scarce and in low supply grands
videos are perceived to be more valuable
and we see this to be true with so many
other amazing channels out there Kurt's
Kazaa again 9.2 million subs post two
times a month three blue one Brown two
million subs post three to four times
per month code Fusion 1.8 million subs
post once a week domain of science learn
engineering the closer look Vsauce and
countless of other examples but perhaps
my favorite example of this let me know
3.2 million subs but get this he posts
one video every two to three months and
guess what
every single time I see a new video from
let me know I click on it right away and
watch it all the way through every
single time without fail
[Music]
let's face it we all dream of getting
rich we all want the Lambos the private
jets the mansions and it's cool to see
people parading these things around on
YouTube but what's more relatable some
guy with his own private jet or Bentley
and penthouse using every chance he gets
to exaggerate and show off versus just a
regular looking dude with a regular
looking clothes living not in a
penthouse or mansion but a duplex to
save money talking about financial
topics that relates to everyone which is
more relatable which is less
intimidating to watch and more
importantly which person can you connect
with more on a personal level as a
viewer this one or this one my opinion
obviously Graham you can see Graham is
congruent with who he probably is in
person an honest frugal guy that's
passionate about making money business
investing and real estate he doesn't put
on a persona like some other people do
he's not shoving expensive courses or
events down your throats and I think
we're getting to a point where people
are starting to realize this and
gravitate towards people on YouTube who
are more authentic and honest with their
audience so reason number two why Graham
is bleeding the YouTube algorithms
he's just honest
for the third reason I think this lesson
I learned from self Golden's book Purple
Cow sums it up pretty perfectly what was
remarkable yesterday is only average
today and mediocre tomorrow see when
Graham was first building his channel
there were other channels out there
doing the same topics as him but what
made his channel remarkable compared to
the other ones is that he was one of the
first ones to have this authenticity and
transparency that we talked about
earlier with adding his style of humor
into the mix as well this is how much
money I have saved so far this month by
not buying avocado toast the result a
breath of fresh air in the finance
YouTube space something that put a
completely different spin on what
everyone else was doing and when you're
remarkably different you stand out you
grow faster people flock to you you get
2.5 million views on a credit card
unboxing video but if you're just
copying everyone else you blend in with
everyone else and you grow way slower in
fact I would say that every channel
that's grown super fast was because they
were remarkable they chose to be
original instead of trying to copy what
works case in point if you look back to
my older videos I'll admit I was just
trying to copy Graham too much because I
was a big fan and because of that I grew
really slowly because it just brings us
back to the lesson from stuff Godin
grands video style that I was copying
was remarkable yesterday when I tried
copying that remark ability it came out
just average today and tomorrow my old
videos would just be mediocre along with
every other copycat video on YouTube can
you still grow on YouTube by just
copying what already works definitely
but if you want to grow and get the kind
of views and subscribers that in a
nutshell has Graham Stefan has you have
to be remarkable there's just no way
around it and if you think about it even
though you can grow on YouTube by just
copying what works is that the kind of
Internet legacy you want to leave that
you just copied everyone is that
stuffing
you would be proud of looking back it's
definitely not for me so why is Graham
Stefan beating the YouTube algorithm
like many things it's pretty simple but
just hard to put into practice his
videos are scarce he puts his audience
first he's authentic and not trying to
put on some mask but most importantly
his videos are remarkable but if we take
a step back isn't this how we find
success with anything in life putting
the customer first being authentic being
remarkably original I think so and if
you do the same based on all the
examples I've just given you you will
probably find success as well whoo this
was a fun video to make a couple of
notes before you guys go but before that
much like Kurt's Kazaa these videos are
taking like more and more hours for me
to make it as the week's go by it may
not be on their scale of like 4 to 500
hours but it's still a lot so in classic
Graham fashion if you're listening to my
voice right now go ahead and put in the
comments down below I watched to the
very end because that on top of all the
other stuff I just talked about does
give a really nice boost so closing
remarks are there other channels out
there that don't follow exactly what I
said to a tee in this video and still
get a ton of engagement a ton of views
and subscribers of course there are but
one thing that I've really learned going
from an absolute beginner to I would say
like at least intermediate entrepreneur
right now in the space is that there are
like an infinite ways to go about things
and to find success however you define
that and when I was first getting
started I would get super hung up or
like how exactly did he do this how did
he do this little thing over here if I
were the same pair of underwear that he
wears
I'll get to success faster but it's just
not like that in reality just take like
the general philosophies like being
authentic all the stuff I just mentioned
in this video and cherry-pick the
specific strategies that fits your needs
and who you are as a person the best so
thank you so much for watching it to the
very end you guys and I hope this video
will live up to the high expectations
I just set in this video and I'm not
like a total hypocrite and if you
enjoyed this style of hopefully visually
pleasing entrepreneur videos please
consider subscribing and turning on the
notification bell and over oh just you
guys coming back here all the time
because you enjoy my videos just means
the world to me if you really want to
support this channel seamlessly for free
you can also bookmark my Amazon homepage
affiliate link and using it when you
shop that way I get a tiny bit of
commission every time you make a
purchase and pretty much all the money I
get from that goes straight back into
the channel to make better videos for
you guys so why not you have been
awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]